bonsoir blanche maison la relation des
pourparlers entre donc chefs d'état en
des quatre membres du quad états unis
australie japon est un de ceux là peut
être considéré comme une menace pour la
chine
écoutez pas vraiment à ce stade
naturellement la chine protestera dira
que les états unis sont en train
d'essayer de former un nouveau une
nouvelle alliance militaire du type de
l'otan en extrême orient comme ils l'ont
dit d'ailleurs en novembre dernier
lorsque les quatre mêmes pays ont mené
des manoeuvres aéronavales dans les eaux
dans les eaux du pacifique
et effectivement il faut comprendre que
la chine a depuis toujours un sentiment
d'enfermement à tort ou à raison parce
que elle est séparée du pacifique par le
japon par l'archipel japonais
il ya d'ailleurs et c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles elle revendique
l'ilsi coucou qui est actuellement sous
la gestion du japon et puis de la même
manière dans la mer de chine du sud elle
revendique que les archipels des
paracels et des spratleys qui sont
contestés par qui a par le vietnam et
par d'autres d'autres pays de la région
et puis surtout au milieu de cette zone
se trouve la grande île de taiwan qui
fait partie de la chine puisque
d'ailleurs tous les pays qui ont les
relations diplomatiques avec pékin
considère considérer qu'il ya une seule
chine et que taiwan en fait partie les
chinois regardent avec beaucoup
d'attention ce qui se passe à taïwan
et si par davanture si d'aventuré un
gouvernement taïwanais déclaré
unilatéralement l'indépendance avec ou
sans l'appui des états unis eh bien ça
provoquerait certainement une
intervention militaire chinois mais cela
dit la chine n'est pas restée inactive
elle a joué délibérément la carte
économique
alors d'abord il faut il faut répéter
que la chine le premier partenaire
économique des trois pays asiatiques
dont nous parlons
le japon l'inde et l'australie
et puis deuxième élément en novembre la
chine à reporter un succès diplomatique
en enrôlant deux de ces pays
le japon et l'australie dans la
signature d'un vaste traité de
libre-échange qui couvrent l'essentiel
de l'asie pas l'inde parce que l'inde
qui participent à la négociation a
décidé un an auparavant
de sortir de cette négociation et par
conséquent de ne pas signer le traité
parce qu'elle craignait d'être submergé
par les biens de consommation chinois à
bas coûts et puis peut être aussi
qu'elle ne voulait pas participer à cet
ensemble
devinez par la chine donc effectivement
on voit là le rôle des grandes
puissances dans cette région est une
manifestation de la rivalité systémique
entre les états unis et la chine
alors ok blanchemaison quelles sont les
perspectives d'avenir de ce coin
équateur rond ont chois alors à ce stade
on c'est difficile c'est difficile à
dire parce que ça n'est pas une alliance
spirit r et on a bien vu
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure que les
ministres les quatre ministres qui se
sont réunis quatre mises affaires
étrangères et là il ya la semaine
dernière ont discuté d'un tas de sujets
d'actualité bien sûr le coc vide
bien sûr la situation économique nous
aussi la sécurité dans la région
en élargissant les sujets en sortant de
la sécurité ce groupement se donne une
relative légitimité légitimité régional
puisqu'il ne se présente pas comme ayant
des finalités purement sécuritaire ou
aux militaires mais si la rencontre peut
enfin la discussion peut bien les
internet est un succès après demain le
problème est qu'il y aura d'autres
candidats parce que pourquoi est-ce que
l'australie ferait partie du quad et pas
la nouvelle zélande
pourquoi est-ce que le japon ferait
partie du quad et pas la corée du sud
sans parler d'autres pays qui
bossi est intéressé comme le vietnam ou
d'autres pays d'asie du sud est
et là les etats unis auront sans doute
un choix à faire soit à donner à cette à
cet embryon de l'organisation une
direction plutôt dirigé contre la chine
quel que soit le régime politique des
pays qui en font partie
ou bien ces temps en temps en tout cas
la tendance initiale de monsieur kringen
le secrétaire d'état américain est sans
doute de joe biden données plutôt
l'aspect d'une d'une alliance des
démocraties contre les autocraties dont
contre la chine et aussi contre le
régime militaire de birmanie d'ailleurs
les ministres des affaires étrangères
qui sont réunis la semaine dernière les
visas sanger du quad ont pris position
pour le retour à la démocratie en
birmanie
donc l'avenir est assez incertain
actuellement on est un peu à la croisée
des chemins et on verra en fonction la
discussion qui aura lieu entre les chefs
d'état de gouvernement vendredi
quel sera le le stade futur la question
c quatre et un ski et poursuivre
vraiment les mêmes objectifs
non pas vraiment pour le japon c'est
évidemment un très bon exemple de la
stratégie au pacifique et le préconisent
depuis plusieurs années et dont le
premier ministre précédent au japon
monsieur chine soit ab s'était fait
l'avocat pour l'australie c'est
simplement et bien la sécurité dans la
partie ouest du pacifique
elle ne s'intéresse pas à d'autres
éléments pour les états unis
c'est peut-être l'embryon en effet d'une
alliance des démocraties asiatiques
contre les régimes dictatoriaux ou
autoritaires ou c'est peut-être un
cordon sanitaire qui vise à contenir
la montée en puissance de la chine mais
pour l'un de c'est peut-être quelque
chose de complètement différent puisque
l'un d'eux ne souhaitent pas souscrire
d'alliance militaire
pour elle c'est une carte supplémentaire
dans un jeu diplomatique qui dans le
fond est un jeu tous azimuts
c'est à dire que l'inde s'efforce
d'avoir des rapports les meilleures
possibles avec la plupart des pays du
monde
elle a d'ailleurs conclu un très grand
nombre de partenariats stratégiques
il se trouve que le premier d'entre eux
a été conclu en 1998 avec la france que
d'autres ont suivi avec la russie en
2000 pour renouer avec les liens
traditionnels que l'inde avait avec
l'union soviétique et d'autres ensuite
en 2004 avec le royaume uni avec les
états unis
puis d'autres avec d'autres pays par
conséquent l'inde ne veux pas avoir un
ami trop exclusif qui seraient les états
unis mais elle veut avoir comme ami
aussi les états unis et en effet ça
rendra le jeu un petit peu difficile
pour monsieur byden dans la discussion
avec nareva maudit d'autant plus que
narindra mode y avait eu une très bonne
entente avec donald train puisqu'ils se
sont rencontrés à plusieurs reprises et
que dans le fond les états unis
s'étaient rapprochés sensiblement de
l'inde
à cette occasion donc l'inde a des
soucis en effet géostratégique
c'est une puissance nucléaire et joue de
la dissuasion c'est une puissance aussi
militaire classique qui surveille ses
frontières mais en même temps elle veut
garder les mains libres et avoir les
meilleures relations possibles avec le
plus grand nombre possible de pays
merci toad blanche maison pour votre
analyse